no you laugh you lose
let's go gamers dinosaurs when they see
the asteroid coming down
oh look it's the loud mike guy oh god
stop buying the blue yeti microphones my
god
it's like oh i gotta i guess i'll stream
i guess i'll buy the mic that everyone
has
stop bro that's larry from veggietales
oh my god it's him oh i cannot unsee it
now
that's larry from veggie tales they even
have the teeth and everything
how did he figure out how to stream just
stream trudeau when a bottle of black
paint is within
its proximity
come on he even covered his hands who
does that
it's so many times you know if you do a
mistake once
fine a couple times fine but enough
times
and it's just become real oh god oh no
i take back everything i just said okay
you can make as many mistakes as
possible
it doesn't mean anything i swear it
means nothing
coincident in society if society i tell
you
at least you won't catch me in blackface
that's my only track record
so what good things have you done felix
well
i didn't l m f o
a i can't read cross-console play is
toxic
wait there's cross console play now who
thought that was a good idea
hey you hey how are you
bro they got ranch damn i love that
that's hilarious
it's like we're bringing gamers together
finally xbox and playstation can play
together it's we're doing such a great
thing
for gamers united reality
we got ranch i wasn't doing a black man
voice by the way just super clear that
was just a random voice
i would never ever
imitate black man boys that's racist my
gamer
danny devito better make me act up
danny danny devito
more like danny don't wanna veto veto is
latin for
luke so no that's not danny devotion
he's way hotter than that danny devotion
i'm not gonna lie i'd freak danny devito
as long as he covers up anything from
neck to bottom
i don't want to see that that's
disgusting don't tell marcia but i would
preach that in the video
this is peak comedy so i went to
chipotle because i need to do some
self-care and since chipotle and
caribbel start with a c
that means eating chipotle is a form of
self-care and no you can't tell me
different
also guac check i love guac and i'm
covering this whole thing in guac
because i'm an adult and i can and
self-care life hack you can use your
leftover guac as a face mask
i guess you could say i walk a little
something on my face did you like that
pun because
i did not only will the avocado make
your face feel better
it'll make your chips taste better too
and this is what self-care looks like
i'm sorry i'm sorry you had to watch
that i apologize
fact while we do have this a little bit
of a second i want to i've seen this
grab this uh this is a classic
monster right here that's right i don't
know why we call it that one
don't know why we're calling that cold
one duncan you got a problem do you like
the test of that black monster
let's just go to the game this is
getting out of control just getting out
of control was that set up it was too
good
you got a problem guys do you like the
chest of that black because he hasn't
tasted it yet and then he goes in and
then it registers it's so funny
[Laughter]
this is why you drink g-fuel i don't
know how many times i gotta say it
drink g fuel code pewdiepie there's a
discount
i'm in charge i'm in charge i'm the only
one with a gun i'm in charge
yeah that looks like critical take take
your shirt off
what game yes to me come on down kid
let's have a drink you're messy
you saved me
oh yeah i feel like i've seen it
yes kevin don't meet
uh don't make me don't make
me make don't make
you don't this isn't that the drinking
room
don't make me look
like a liar
[Laughter]
dominique the master of puns absolutely
incredible delivery
[Music]
come on dr bell you can get them
oh
okay that was impressive this
okay you suck that was epic i wish you'd
swallowed it or something that'd be
beautiful
that's you right um no
what are you what are you doing look at
you go
wow nice catch 3 000 pounds 40 miles an
hour
wow i love when these just become me
going
haha funny haha oh wait not supposed to
laugh oh
shame ah i guess i lost
[Music]
jesus christ
top notch 10 out of 10. that was
beautiful
i want more of that
[Music]
oh man this needs
cold-hearted killer bro what is this new
filter
is that real how can you get scared of
that
from the [ __ ] oh these are pretty cool
bananas
goodnight girl i see you tomorrow
like i wanna laugh but they're so bad no
no stop stop trying to do loud is funny
okay i would never do that
ah it's a grinch man i'm out here you
already know man just cool and you feel
bro
what you doing bro it's my block he's
working
you know who i am bro who the [ __ ] is
you you don't know
well you finna find out your barbecue
boy sunday school special shirt ass boy
huh like an exotic cricket your little
glass what tap dancing frog looking ass
boy
and you're out here with them roses are
red violets are blue
my booty looking [ __ ] i don't
know about you guys but i'm freaking
villager
what are you gonna do sue me you can't
i'm swedish it's the only good thing we
have
here comes to oh no no
no don't mix jojo with family guy
for bad illegal
okay that was epic
[Music]
oh no no no don't feed rotten meat
stop he doesn't want it
oh my god
oh god it's much like if you're crying
too
that was incredibly sad i was gonna say
so sad but then i realized that's a dead
meme
so i said incredibly sad instead big
brain
what does anyone watch
clean russell
[Applause]
oh my god russell
well technically if he else clean
russell
then he actually made a bigger mess
because he made balloons on the floor
so if anything he shouldn't be sharing
his back actually
i felt like a boy's locker room girls be
like if again i gotta change tampons
boys be like clean russell
no that's so sad
the [ __ ] live adaptation
nice abby i i
really really swear to god here
sounded like keemstar didn't it i i
really yeah
out here live we will have much more
from the tiny community
of rachel nevada at 6 30. reporting live
joe martells 13 action news okay that
was nice
everyone's getting so good at editing
bro there it is
oh my god i've see i have seen this
that's illegal you can't do that anymore
[Music]
still funny though a membership figure
stood at 169
800 and you can do it jacob
700 listen properly
[Music]
all right gamers be honest did you
scatter or did you fallura
let me know in the comments down below
and also wait did i have any more oh my
god the baby edits are so good i love
this meme
hamburger hamburger
that's hilarious
okay that was good i like that one
what is this
yeah that's right gamers thank you for
watching this episode of scotland can't
be too loud
again but did you laugh let me know in
the comments down below
and see you gamers next time hey dole
hey hey
what you haven't tried tuber simulated
seriously
after 50 million outros my hatch
maya i can't damn it maya
come here just down it's still relevant
just download it